jean jacques sylvestre bonjour alors
tout d'abord en guélat merkel at elle
les moyens de redresser l'union
européenne
je pense que non seulement elle en a les
moyens mais il en a aussi l'ambition
parce que c'est son dernier mandat
quelque part souvenez-vous l'année
dernière à la même époque angela merkel
était politiquement condamnée elle avait
perdu la majorité en allemagne elle
avait perdu toute influence celle
organisée même son départ
aujourd'hui après la crise du corona
bien au gala merkel n'a jamais été aussi
populaire est aussi légitime pour sortir
l'allemagne de la crise et pour ce faire
elle a compris avec son peuple
l'allemagne avait besoin de l'europe
comme l'europe d'ailleurs a besoin de
l'allemagne
aujourd'hui les rapports de force ont
changé l'allemagne faisait cavalier seul
et renier économiquement sur le monde
avec la sophistication de ses machines
outils ses exportations aujourd'hui est
bien la chine s'est repliée sur elle
même elle se ferme un peu les etats unis
se sont mis au protectionnisme
l'allemagne va donc avoir besoin des
marchés européens des européens elle a
toutes les cartes pour faire changer
l'europe
elle a une popularité en allemagne est
considérable comme jamais dans la rue je
pense que c'est le chef d'état en europe
qui est le plus populaire était la
gestion de la crise lui a permis de
s'imposer elle peut faire accepter au
peuple allemand des projets et des
politiques et paraissait complètement
tabou jusqu'à maintenant ensuite sa
deuxième carte
c'est qu'elle a le soutien au sein de
l'europe de deux paires de personnalités
qui sont ses amis etc est là et qu'elle
a mis en place pratiquement avec avec la
collaboration de la france elle à la
christine lagarde qui est à la
présidence de la banque centrale
européenne est elle à ursula von der
leyen qui est la présidente de la
commission d'un côté des signes lagarde
tient les cordons de la bourse
et puis de l'autre et bien la présidente
veille sur la gouvernance quotidienne de
cette technocratie sur laquelle en a dit
beaucoup de choses et beaucoup de
critiques et puis la troisième carte en
main et bien c'est qu'elle a l'appui des
grands industriels allemands et des
syndicats qui ont été éprouvés par la
crise du corona par la crise économique
la force de l'allemagne
elle s'est construite le disait sur les
succès de ses exportations tout le monde
sait que ça va être beaucoup plus
difficile maintenant le patronat
allemand a compris qu'il aurait besoin
des marchés européens
mais pour avoir accès au marché européen
eh bien il faut un peu protégés des
économies euros
elle il faut protéger ses clients or
vous avez des clients en europe qui sont
fragiles qui sont dans un état de
difficultés notamment toute l'europe du
sud
populaire dans la campagne allemande
écouté par les élites en gala merkel
peut imaginer un changement de modèle
économique aux niveaux d'europe
l'allemagne a quand même des grands
défis à relever parce que l'europe est
très divisé entre le nord et le sud
s'est très divergents vous savez le
premier défi c'est le défi de la relance
une relance budgétaire de façon à
relancer des économies chaque état en
europe ne peut pas s'en sortir seul
c'est tous les états ensemble de façon
solidaire alors l'allemagne a déjà passé
un accord un préalable avec avec la
france une sur cette idée de lancer un
grand emprunt qui seraient mutualisés au
niveau de l'europe et on suit dont
l'argent serait distribuée aux pays les
plus en difficulté alors ça c'est
totalement nouveau pour l'allemagne pour
l'allemagne c'était un tabou et été
accrochés aux critères de maastricht
accroché à l'orthodoxie budgétaire elle
imposer une espèce de rigueur budgétaire
à tous les pays aujourd'hui elle lâche
un peu les les cordons de la bourse
cela dit elle doit convaincre aussi les
états qu'on appelle des étapes frugaux
en europe c'est-à-dire la suède le
danemark l'autriche les pays-bas mais de
l'autre côté et bien elle a tous les
pays du sud qui ont le plus besoin
d'argent alors pour résoudre la crise
économique engalin merkel devra éviter
une crise politique majeure entre et les
européens elle peut le faire
alors elle a un deuxième défi c'est ça
va être de trouver un accord avec le
royaume uni parce qu'on va rentrer dans
la discussion avec le bric site
mais c'est elle qui va mener la
négociation avec boris johnson les
discussions sont bloquées actuellement
la science bière et la france d'ailleurs
sont en faveur d'une coopération assez
forte avec le royaume uni à une
condition une condition c'est que barry
johnson respectent les normes
européennes
c'est à dire les normes sanitaires les
normes sociales les normes fiscales les
croyez moi sur ce point là c'est pas
c'est pas c'est pas gagné sur le dossier
de l'environnement est ce qu'aujourd'hui
l'europe avoir une position commune à
votre asie oui alors là hélas angela
merkel est assez bien placé parce
qu'elle connaît des écologistes à elle
elle gère
allemagne avec les écologistes depuis
pas mal de temps
elle a eu des difficultés avec les
écologistes qui avaient des positions
radicales des positions dures sont
d'ailleurs les écolos au moment de
l'accord gouvernemental qui a dépassé
avait demandé par exemple l'arrêt des
centrales nucléaires en allemagne et la
réouverture des centrales au charbon ce
qui n'était pas très très écologiste est
aujourd'hui et bien elle a réussi à
faire changer un peu les écolos
allemands qui avec la crise du
coronavirus accepte un certain nombre de
de compromis elle sait très bien et les
écolos allemands savent très bien que ce
fut une erreur l'allemagne est devenue
un des pays les plus pauvres en europe
il faut changer des sources énergétiques
passer aux alternatifs et peut-être
aussi passé au nucléaire racheter de
l'électricité nucléaire à la france qui
serait un comble ou alors relancé ses
propres ses propres centrales sur le
terrain de l'écologie en gala merkel a
réussi à faire changer les attitudes et
écologique allemand vers un compromis
plus acceptable avec l'économie de
croissance l'économie d'emplois elle a
fait changer l'allemagne elle pourra
peut-être frange faire changer les
européens merci jean marc sylvestre pour
toutes ces précisions je rappelle que
vous êtes journaliste éditorialiste
économique m